we got like 40 of our brands
opted in within an hour and
more than 60 percent opted in after like
another follow-up email so
without having to speak with any of
those brands because they saw the value
and
right so so that's e-commerce that like
we're
very excited about like the growth there
and it's becoming like a very meaningful
channel for us
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech
it's been a year since my good friend
amir zwickel joined me here
in 20 minute leaders and it is
definitely time for another episode show
fields is one of the most amazing
companies i've
met with with incredible spaces in in
miami new york and more
and this past year during covid it's
been difficult and it's been weird and
it's been
fun and exciting for them as they've
pivoted and they've realized
different potential avenues and
different paths and and i'm really
excited to host amir here again
so please help me welcome amir's weekl
co-founder and cro at show fields
amir is a serial entrepreneur with a
specialization in real estate
development
here in his bachelor's in law in
business and his master's in law from
idc
his master's in political science from
tel aviv university and his masters in
real estate development from columbia
university in the city of new york
at show fields amir oversees the revenue
team and leads the real estate
part of the venture from construction to
sourcing and negotiating new properties
as part of overseeing show fields growth
plans
and extension strategy welcome amir
amir zwickel how are you all the way
from new york with the
six week old newborn thank you for
coming on the show again
i'm good how are you thank you for
having me uh
thank you thank you for making the time
sure wonderful my pleasure always happy
to talk
um and um yeah it's been a
hell of a year um hell of a year
a healthy year and uh excited about
what's
coming you know uh finally
we see the light at the end of the
tunnel and uh
can start uh focusing on the future um
so excited about that you know we talked
last time about a year ago
uh you were one of the very first guests
i had on the show
and we were talking just as kovit was
rolling out and we met
in the show fields building in new york
and i believe bond street and i remember
coming in and it was
this it's the spectacular building and
anybody who hasn't been there i really
hope they get a chance because it's
it's just such a phenomenal experiential
activity where you come in and you
observe a new type of
real estate a new type of retail
extremely innovative understanding that
every
every centimeter in the space is
accounted for
and right when we did the episode it was
when kovitz started teaching us that
things are shifting a little bit and
you know the physical space that we're
observing you know needs to become
digitalized in some way shape or form
and show fields was all about
physical it was all about coming to
experience retail again
in a new way and you were ta and we were
talking a little bit about the ways that
show fields is adapting and the way that
you're thinking about
about you know this new world and here
we are almost a year later and and i'm
really excited to hear about
you know what did happen with show
fields and where are you today and what
did you learn
throughout covet about consumer behavior
and about leadership and about moving
forward
so take take me back a year from now a
year ago
what happened what happened with covet
and show fields
well um a lot has happened
um so i think like if i need to
summarize two main things happened to
show fields as a result of covid
first being um it created challenges in
the short term
we had to close our new york store for
more than three months
uh um we had to postpone our opening in
miami in a few months
and that created challenges in the short
term that required us to be creative
around
we can do take i'm sorry for that um
hold on
that's the point of the show yeah but
uh that's the fifth member of the family
um yeah anyways
so it created challenges in the short
term that required us to
basically take steps to compensate for
that launch our e-com
earlier than originally planned um
and basically making changes bring
additional cash from
existing investors and new investors to
not only
survive this crisis but also to position
ourselves
best to be strong on the other side of
that um and i'm happy to say that like
we're pretty successful in doing so
the other thing that happened to show
fields as a result of kovit
is that it actually created a huge
opportunity for us
um because when you think about it all
the trends that
show fields was built upon um are
strengthening as a result of kovid
so starting with experiential retail uh
i think it was already very hard to get
people to shop outside of their house in
the last
few years and it's going to be even
harder it's very clear
so everything that is that would have to
be
around experiential retail and i think
like we're already one of the only
companies
in in the retail industry that is not
only speaking about experiential retail
but is also like
building experiential retail second
trend being like e-commerce e-commerce
is going to continue to grow i think
like we're gonna
we agree on that um and and with that
the marketing budgets that brands need
to spend online in order to get in front
of the number of eyeballs that they need
to get in front
customer acquisition cost online that
has been increasing consistently in the
last few years is going to going to
continue to increase and we're going to
see more and more brands
trying to create touch points with
consumers on other channels
in order to decrease their attack online
so that red is gonna strengthen and
continue
we believe uh third thing being ex
flexibility in retail which is very
obvious brands would wanna take less
risk
and i think would be less likely to sign
on a long term
10 or 15 year lease and they would want
to do
retail in the least risk risky way
possible
while still maintaining you know being
respectful towards their brand elevated
and elegant without compromising their
brand value and that's exactly what we
offer and lastly as you said like the
connectivity between the digital and the
physical is key
being able to attribute enhancement in
online sales for example as a result of
physical exposure
is something that is very important is
going to be even more important
and i think that's something that we've
been doing pretty well um
so with all that in mind we we were very
optimistic about the future and the
opportunities around it
for us and um you know when you look at
the metrics that
we're looking at in terms of demand that
we see from brands
we actually see that like the number of
brands approaching show fields and
asking to join the platform has been
increasing month over month uh anywhere
between 30 to 50
since kovid started which is
counterintuitive to what's going
on like in the retail industry right now
um so
we're very excited about that and so
what i'm hearing you say here is that
you know you're looking at this from two
verticals you have the very short term
verticals saying you know okay yes we
had to delay by three months
the yeah we had to close the store for
three months we had to close we had to
delay by a few months the opening of
miami we had to get more cash from
existing and new investors
it created a lot of you know a lot of
balagan
internally but then you're saying but
wait but then there's this bigger trend
that we're observing and if we look at
the long-term growth of show fields
we're actually seeing all around the
market adapting to the same
sort of um you know thesis that you came
up with originally saying
stores are not going to want to sign
long-term leases they're not they don't
need huge spaces
they can make do with certain spaces
e-commerce is going to get harder with
the cost of cac increasing and here in
show fields is an opportunity to
capitalize on that and while these three
months
or four months may hurt in the long term
there's a lot of added benefit is that
is that sort of the thinking that you
have going on
exactly you know when you think about
like few years back like 10 years or 15
years like
building a website for a company it was
a million dollar project 6 to 12 months
super complex if i need to make an
analogy for
like real estate it's huge cup backs up
front investment
you know it was it used to be in order
to open uh
a website right and then shopify came to
the world and other companies came to
the world and said
instead of cup packs instead of huge
complexity in
upfront investment we'll do it like no
barriers to entry whatsoever
you can do ecom within an hour and
instead of like paying upfront
pay us like a monthly fee let's convert
capex to opex right
right and our promise to you brent that
we're gonna always provide you with the
best tools to do eco
and what happened then is that like
there was an explosion of creativity
um the age of creation no barriers to
entry whatsoever
and the democratization was totally lost
so if someone wants to open a brand for
mattresses today
and want to compete with casper on
clicks for mattresses it's inaccessible
for them same way as real estate on
fifth ave
is inaccessible right right and now
what's what's happening
is that like it's impossible to stand
out online without like spending
a huge amount of money so all of them
are coming back
the thing is that the barriers
strengthen to the physical world they've
never been so high
so what we want to be we want to be what
shopify
is for e-com for physical retail we want
to convert their capex to opex spare
something monthly
no barriers for entry no upfront risk
come join physical and open a touch
point
rather than a sale point right yeah
i think that's just that's just
so you're you're sitting there and
covered is starting is this the same
are you as clear on this thesis
when i first met you and bond street
back in new york well were you as clear
on that or did this really solidify
partially as a result of what happened
in this fa in this past year
it's a good question uh we had this this
is all along the way but i think like we
now like see the business more like as a
platform that
our vision is in the next few years to
have thousands of different touch points
on this platform
for many different kinds so once a brand
on boards to the platform
they never have a reason to live right
so some of those touch points are high
street
physical retail like the flagship we
have in one or
like the flagship we have in miami some
of them would be within shopping centers
some touch points would be within
airports or on flights or within hotels
so wherever consumers exist we want to
allow brands to meet them
today when we look at our business we
have three main channels
one being flagships we have one in new
york open for around two years
um another one in miami we want to keep
on opening
more of those in the next few years in
other major cities around the world
second channel that we have is
e-commerce we have more than 400 brands
and more than 200 artists by the way
more general
we more than triple the amount of brands
on our platform
uh since covid hit so um on e-com
few very interesting things are
happening there
um with the the two most interesting
things are one
uh different collaborations that we have
with enterprise level brands such as
american express
where we basically the value that we
bring to the table there
is one our access to beautiful endless
amount of brands and two
our ability our technology that allows
us to onboard brands within minutes to a
multi-vendor platform that actually
works
that allows them to do the play that
they want and
and basically amplify our website and
create a lot of value
for other brands that like live there uh
which
in times like that i have to take you
back because
uh when when we walked up the stairs i
remember this vividly i remember you
explaining to me
the onboarding process that you have for
a new brand
in the physical space and you were
telling me how pretty much
seamlessly you have a designing team you
do everything online and like this
they they have a store and it's a
beautiful store you walk in there is a
representative they're demoing the
product
you can you can spend hours there and
it'll be a much higher quality probably
than they would be able to do themselves
over the span of months of preparation
and so now you're telling me about this
new magic where how you're on boarding
within a matter of minutes new brands
this is not you know a single amazon
seller
that is selling out of their garage this
is a full-on brand that has a messaging
that has
that has you know their own strategy and
you're bringing them on and you know i'm
making this analogy here because i'm
saying you know the the
like the the intelligence of what you're
doing here is its ability to work
together with brands at such a seamless
way
and in this beautiful integration that i
just love seeing the parallel of what it
was before
and how you're translating now obviously
the much higher scale
it's even becoming more interesting when
we're speaking about brands that are
already on our platform because it's
even easier
um so the other thing that is very
interesting that's happening on our
e-commerce platform right now is that
um and i'll be able to disclose like by
name very soon but we're about to
finalize a partnership with a very big
media group um that basically has like
very very high traffic online they work
with very very strong brands
but what the the type of brands that
they don't work with is the long tail of
brands which is exactly like
most of the brands in the world and the
type of brands that like we have access
to
so this collaboration is basically
building a new
um ecom platform on top of their website
where they would be responsible to bring
the traffic
and will be responsible to um to bring
the brands they're creating the most
like high quality type of content around
this brand so they get value as a result
of that and also
sales and the interesting part about it
is that like
we basically allowed our brands to opt
in um
this new channel and we got like
40 of our brands opted in within an hour
and more than 60 cents opted in
after like another follow-up email so
without having to speak with any of
those brands because they saw the value
and
right so so that's e-commerce that like
we're
very excited about like the growth there
and it's becoming like a very meaningful
channel for us
um the third channel which is maybe the
most like the newest thing we have is
called out of home
uh we developed a concept called magic
box which is basically pure retail as a
service where
show fields can basically create a
smaller version of the show fields magic
and take any type of square footage that
you want curve
it out and use our network network of
brands and artists
to create a highly experiential rotating
marketplace to meet them
where we basically become partners of
the landlord
or the operator or the retailer because
like this could also like be
uh done with retailers so many different
scenarios for the magic box that were
working on each one of them
but the main one is shopping centers so
think about shopping malls in the world
curving out an area that is usually
referred to as a common space
we do like we bring our network to build
it we activate it we operate it we do
everything
and the landlord gets to one activity
space that wasn't activated before
to monetize it as at least as well as it
would have been monetized by traditional
tenants
and three which is the most important
thing because like even without one and
two
only three would make them do it they
get to have the most sophisticated lead
generation machine
inside their mall because when we on
board these like
20 brands or 30 brands to like a magic
box type of activation
it's very easy to stand there in front
of the data with the landlord few months
in
and identify which ones were like so
successful
that they would that it would actually
make sense for them to take their own
story in the more it's literally
it's totally data driven real estate
it's unbelievable
exactly and like and and and i think
what's
innovative about it is that like for us
at least like we're not like a
traditional tenant anymore
we're more tool that landlords can use
because if i prove that like i hit the
metrics that i'm speaking about
why don't they do it in their entire
portfolio right
because they have like a lot of them
have enough so there is like 1.5
billion square foot of retail in the us
that are ultra prime location
and someone is already paying rent for
right
so um you know similarly to
uber who's the largest taxi company in
the world without owning any taxi
we want to be the largest retailer in
the world without like signing any
traditionalists
uh so that's the vision it's a very big
and uh
um vision but like we
we're moving towards that and we're
working on a first proof of concept that
we're gonna execute on
by the end of the month uh so really
around the corner
with like one of the largest like small
groups in the world
and we're like uh working with the
others as well
uh we have similar initiatives with like
um
other types of touch points like
retailers that we
were working on partnering with so this
is really really exciting and like we
see the growth of show fields in the
next few years
coming from both of those channels like
flagships and
uh magic box with obviously ecom in the
background contributing everything
i'm just connecting but
i think that what you're describing here
uh
you know and first of all i have to say
that i i what i love most about the show
is that we can have this awesome
conversation it doesn't need to be in a
formal studio it doesn't have to be
you know with makeup and all the you
know we're just doing it from home you
have a
six week old newborn baby you have
another beautiful kid you have the dog
your
your parents are visiting this this is
you know how
you know i i like this show and and so
thank you for for bringing that out
and and i just love having you here
again for the second time i
i love show fields i loved it from the
second that i walked into the store
and i saw something that i've never seen
before and it's so rare
to walk into a place and to see
something that you've never seen before
you never thought of you never thought
of it as you know as
something that that could and should be
and you know i can only bet that you
know a few years from now when it
becomes abundant around the world
people are not going to remember what
it's like to have just a traditional
regular store that has one brand and
doesn't have much experience
he just has a bunch of products so i i'm
really excited to look back at the on
this episode
you know 10 15 years from now when the
world is in a completely different place
amir thank you for coming i have three
short questions for you are you ready
yes all right number one favorite
subject in school
well i think it was geography um
and you know like the one thing i like
doing the most is traveling around the
world and i think like uh this passion
started back then like i was lucky
enough to
travel a lot with my parents when i was
a kid um
and since then i'm trying to like use my
free time for that
a lot so amazing
role model fictional or real somebody
that
had an impact on you that you look up to
as a role model
uh well there are several um
i'm currently reading the book of frank
lori who is the person behind westfield
and extremely inspiring um
person who built an empire from nothing
holocaust survivor um
funny enough it's like his uh parents
are from hungary
in slovakia which is exactly my origin
um
so i connect to that relate to that as
well but like
very very interesting and also like a
very recommended book it's called
pushing the limits
uh but frank louie is like definitely an
inspiration
amazing amir three words that you would
choose to describe yourself or if i were
to ask
any of your colleagues at show fields
how would they describe amir's wiggle
uh it's a tough question um i think like
when
last time we spoke like like i said
hard-working
um it's definitely the the first word
that like
people that work with me would describe
me with um
i wanna i think like i'm very passionate
about what i'm doing i don't think there
is
anything else that like i could do in my
life right now that i would be more
passionate about
um and i see myself as a go-getter like
i i get done and it's like
important for me um i think this would
be like the the
three best words to describe um
myself um
thank you very very much this was
wonderful thank you for coming again
and i look forward i look forward to the
third time
uh enjoy the time of the newborn and
then
yeah hopefully like next time there is
like new
new more stuff to say and it was a
pleasure as always
for now bye